[Musique]
on était très heureux cette année de
refaire des vidéos
urbaines et architecturales du quartier
de l'École polytechnique dans ses
visites on essaie de montrer à la fois
les bâtiments qui sont en cours de
construction et déjà livrés et de donner
un aperçu de ce que va être le quartier
à terme aujourd'hui on a pu vraiment
parcourir le quartier dans son
intégralité depuis le quartier de
corbeille et le château donc le quartier
voisin jusque vraiment au cœur de
l'école politique en essayant de
traverser vraiment les différentes
atmosphères qui sont celles du quartier
et puis on s'est promené aussi dans les
parties plus centrales du quartier ce
qu'on appelle la bande centrale qui est
vraiment le coeur mixte et urbain du
quartier dans lequel on a implanté les
différentes écoles donc AgroParisTech
qui a ouvert en cette rentrée de
septembre Télécom qui avait ouvert il y
a trois ans et qui va se poursuivre
jusqu'à Polytechnique et donc dans cette
bande centrale on a essayé de mélanger
vraiment les fonctions et colle logement
étudiant des bureaux des labos et des
commerces bien sûr articulés sur les
espaces public principaux qu'on essaye
d'encourager ici sur le plateau de
Saclay l'architecture contemporaine et
de travailler à la fois sur une
cohérence et sur une expression
contemporaine et moderne et en même
temps qu'on espère intemporel de
l'architecture on travaille vraiment sur
ces différentes échelles et qu'on
articule autour d'une chaîne d'espace
public des grands boulevards qui sont
supports de la mobilité douce les vélos
les piétons etc mais également des bus
express et puis des parties des espaces
publics plus centraux plus piétons en
cœur de quartier qui en fait l'objet
d'un traitement de qualité avec beaucoup
de plantations des revêtements en pavés
et qui sont vraiment le support de
l'animation urbaine
aujourd'hui c'est la journée nationale
de l'architecture c'est une journée
exceptionnelle pour nous les architectes
puisque c'est l'idée de pouvoir partager
et de débattre sur la question
architecturale et en l'occurrence ici
donc sur le Moulon
l'habitat s'est fait d'abord dans la
vallée donc il y a d'une part un vrai
sujet qui est la relation avec la vallée
et d'autre part il y a mettre les
conditions de cette urbanité qui va
combiner on va dire une espèce de
d'héritage anglo-saxon du campus donc
d'une idée du parc avec beaucoup de
végétales et aussi l'idée d'un urbanisme
de rue c'est-à-dire avec l'idée de
fabriquer un espace public et une des
rues assez ordinaires dans un contexte
quand même assez exceptionnel du
production architectural qu'on a un peu
rarement en France puisque il y a
beaucoup de concours il y a une vraie
politique architecturale qui est portée
par le paps et université en consultant
des grands architectes dans des concours
et qui a fait l'objet de cette balade
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui puisque on a
été montré ces bâtiments et montrer où
en était cette fabrique de la ville sur
le plateau
[Musique]